- Wir würden heute bei
Herrn Hombach starten.
Dort machen wir eine kleine Pflege
mit Lagern und Betten.
- Alles klar.
- Genau, dann würden wir
den Blutzucker messen
und entsprechend das Insulin spritzen
und dann nochmal die Medikamente
kontrollieren und die ihm verabreichen.
Genau, als Nächstes würden wir
dann zu der nächsten Patientin gehen,
die hat eine infizierte Bisswunde.
- Ach so, okay.
- Genau, die ist von einem Hund
gebissen worden.
Die Wunde hat sich infiziert, ist soweit
von einem Chirurgen versorgt worden
und soll jetzt durch den Pflegedienst,
quasi durch uns, versorgt werden,
bis sie dann abgeheilt ist.
- Okay, das sind zwei.
- Genau, richtig.
Wir würden am Anfang gucken,
dass wir das Übergabebuch lesen,
was die Kollegen eingetragen haben.
Gibt es irgendwelche Informationen,
hat jemand einen Arzttermin
oder irgendwas?
Genau, dann würden wir
die Schlüssel nehmen,
damit wir dann auch
in die Wohnung kommen.
Dann wäre ich soweit bereit.
Hast du noch Fragen?
- Bis jetzt nicht.
- Okay.
Wir würden uns die zwei Schlüssel von
unseren Patienten jetzt erst mal mitnehmen:
Das wäre einmal der Herr Hombach ...
und dann die andere
Patientin noch, ja?
Das sind die zwei Schlüssel,
die wir dann brauchen.
- Ja, alles klar.
Da haben wir die Medikamente.
Genau, die nehmen wir uns mit.